that leads to a feasible position a
boss-up kind of looking up at the stars
which is the universal sign of you know
a GM trying to remember his preparation
and the point of Bishop takes E3 is to
take the tension off of the Knight on e4
and black usually follows this up by
playing E5 I'm pretty sure after Pawn
takes C3
E5 we get just complete pandemonium on
the board
yes E5 or G5 I also see that computer
suggests G5 and E5 vf2 mention two
completely different uh positions might
arrive and what
of course Queen E7 okay clearly black
design Queen A3 check but white does
seem to have this typical idea C for
covering the A3 square and how is black
and C4 already on the board so